for years
they've been called illegal now the
government says
they are essential that's the confusing
reality for
at least half of the 2.4 million farm
workers
who plant and harvest our food here in
the united states
many produce pickers are working under
grueling conditions
with few safety measures in place and
that was already a problem
even before hundreds began testing
positive for coronavirus
in farms across the country
[Music]
after 13 years working in the fields of
southern california
carmelita still does not have legal
status in the u.s
and because of that she cannot even
think about signing up for basic
benefits
like health insurance and she doesn't
qualify for a stimulus
check from the federal government
overcoming these kinds of challenges
isn't anything new for carmelita
what's different is that now she's
terrified of getting sick
by mid-may a vast majority of farm
laborers around the country
say they had still not received masks
gloves or any other protective equipment
from the companies they work for
carmelita had been taking her
own precautions but many of her
co-workers
didn't believe or understand the
outbreak so keeping social distance has
been difficult
with peak harvesting season already
underway farmworker advocates fear
that negligence and lack of education
could lead to a major outbreak
that in turn could further disrupt an
already fragile supply chain
and leave empty shelves in grocery
stores
we're treated as essential workers right
now
because if we don't do this kind of work
the united states is not going to have
food in
in supermarkets food to to feed
the nation one doctor from the same
county carmelita lives in
has been trying to help us
has been going from farm to farm
educating workers about the virus
they live in our community they function
in our society so we want to get
into them and really help them be safe
just trying to provide basic medical
education
on how to keep the infrastructure of our
society safe to keep the rest
not all farms have welcomed him but he
says
some are taking steps to protect their
workers
good farms which hires domestic workers
and international workers with temporary
work permits
is putting hand wash stations in the
fields
part of the work that we're having to do
is
to not only look at the work but also
interface with our teams in both their
personal lives
and the lives of their families
california leads the nation in growing
produce
and is home to 400 000 farm workers
of which an estimated 50 percent are
unauthorized
in mid-april california governor gavin
newsom announced
a one-time covet 19 relief payment of
500
per adult to approximately 150
000 unauthorized immigrants he also said
that farms and other food industry
businesses
must give workers an additional two
weeks of covert 19 sick leave
that would make a huge difference for
carmelita who says her company
normally only gives three sick days per
year
more sick leave right now would help
with the current situation
but this kind of work can be
backbreaking at the best of times
see advocates and the challenges for
america's undocumented farm workers
and ultimately its food supply remain
when carmelita finishes her 12 hour
shifts picking strawberries
she heads to her two children at a
rented room
in a mobile home
she dreams of the security that legal
status would bring america
but the options for applying are limited
and it can be very expensive
the pandemic has only made it harder
president donald trump has used the
outbreak to suspend
most legal immigration temporary guest
worker programs have continued to
protect the food supply
but those programs only cover 10 percent
of farm workers in the u.s
and it doesn't help carmelita since
she's been here without legal status
for more than a decade
immigrants
the blue card is part of a law proposed
by democrats in 2017
that would give agricultural workers the
right to work
and a path to permanent legal status for
them
and their families
sons were born in the u.s making them
american citizens
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
you